i believe that
you believe that corporations are people
so this is a this is a kind of a
politically
dense idea all those kinds of things if
we just throw politics aside if we throw
all of that aside
in which sense do you believe that
corporations are people so um
and how does love connect to that right
so the belief is that groups of people
have some kind of higher level i would
say mesoscopic claim to agency i you
know so so where do i you know
let's let's start with this most people
would say okay individuals have claims
to agency and sovereignty nations we
certainly act as if nations so at a very
large large scale nations have rights to
sovereignty and agency like everyone
plays the game of modernity as if that's
true right we believe france is a thing
we believe the united states is the
thing but to say that groups of people
at a smaller level than that
um
like a family unit is the thing well in
our law in our laws we actually do
encode this concept
i believe that um in a relationship in a
marriage right one partner can sue
for loss of consortium right if someone
breaks up the the marriage or whatever
so these are concepts that even in law
we do respect there is something about
the union and about the family so for me
i don't think it's so weird to think
that groups of people have
a right to
a claim to rights and sovereignty of
some degree i mean we and we we
uh look at our clubs we look at churches
these are we we talk about these
collectives of people as if they have a
real agency to them and then they do but
i think if we take that one step further
and say okay they can accrue resources
well yes check you know by law they can
um they can own land they can
engage in contracts they can do all
these different kinds of things so we in
legal terms
support this idea that groups of people
have rights
where we go wrong on this stuff is that
the most popular version of this is the
for-profit absentee owner corporation
that then is able to amass larger
resources than anyone else in the
landscape anything else any other entity
of equivalent size
and they're able to essentially bully
around individuals whether it's laborers
whether it's people whose resources they
want to capture
they're also able to bully around our
system of representation
which is still tied to individuals right
so
i don't believe that's correct i don't
think it's good that they you know
they're people but they're i
don't think that corporations as people
acting like is a good thing but
the idea that collectives and
collections of people
that we should treat them
philosophically as having
some
agency some agency and some some mass
at a mesoscopic level i think that's an
important thing because one one thing i
do
think
we under appreciate sometimes is
the fact that relationships have
relationships so it's not just
individuals having relationships with
each other
but if you have eight people seated
around a table right each person has a
relationship with each of the others and
that's obvious but then if it's four
couples each couple also has a
relationship with each of the other
couples right the dyads do and if it's
couples but one is the the you know
father mother older and then you know
one of their children and their spouse
that that family unit of four has a
relationship with the other family unit
of four so the idea that relationships
have relationships is something that we
intuitively know in navigating the
social landscape but it's not something
i hear expressed like that um it's
certainly not something that is
i think taken into account very well
when we design these kinds of things so
i think um the reason why i care a lot
about this
is because i think the future of
humanity
requires us to form better sense make
collective sense making units at
something you know around dunbar number
you know half to 5x dunbar
and that's very different than right now
where we
um
defer sense making to massive aging
zombie institutions
or we just do it ourselves we go it
alone go to the dark force of the
internet
so that's really interesting so you've
talked about agency
i think maybe calling it a convenient
fiction at all these different levels
so even at the human individual level
it's kind of a fiction we all believe
because we are like you said made of
cells and cells are made of atoms
so that's a useful fiction and then
there's nations
that seems to be a useful fiction but
it seems like some fictions are better
than others you know there's a lot of
people that argue the fiction of nation
is a bad idea one of them
lives two doors down from me michael
malus he's an anarchist
you know i'm sure there's a lot of
people who are into meditation that
believe the idea
this useful fiction of agency of an
individual is uh troublesome as well we
need to let go of that in order to truly
like to transcend
i don't know i don't know what words you
want to use but suffering or to uh to
elevate the
experience of life
so
you're kind of arguing that okay so we
have some of these useful fictions of
agency
we should add a stronger fiction that we
tell ourselves about the agency of
groups in the hundreds of uh the
uh half of dunbar's number five x
dunbar's number yeah something on that
order and we call them fictions but
really they're rules of the game right
rules that we
we feel are fair or rules that we
consent to
you